aside from your book where can someone
else discover a history of film a lot of
the textbooks around you know David
bordelles textbook is great Jannetty
excellent um watch old movies I find
that you know watching old films on
netflix a great experience don't worry
about what they have you looking at I
feel like flow Barre said about novels
that how wise one would be if one knew
only well five or six novels I think
that if you find an old movie that you
like and it speaks to you you should
watch it a hundred times I think that is
the greatest education about film
history there is I must have seen the
third man by Sir carol reed hundred
times and i think that that has taught
me more about pacing and film lighting
characterization writing and so on than
any kind of broad survey so i personally
feel that there are textbooks around and
you certainly can use them but the best
thing i think you can do is just watch
old movies and when you find one that
really speaks to you by watch it forever
and it'll deeply need your appreciation
of where movies came from so when
someone watches a film more than once
what starts to happen that same film
let's suppose they've seen it twice now
now they're seeing beyond certain things
you begin to see more and you begin to
see how the film is constructed and you
begin to sort of appreciate all the
little things that all the perhaps
people did when you're watching for
example the third man and you notice
that when the woman walks into the room
between two other men and she stands
exactly in front of a portrait of a
woman behind her and then they cut you
realize that the editor is himself
emphasizing the theme of the film which
is this kind of vagrant identity which
is floating around this film's
mysterious person who is neither live
nor dead
and you begin to sort of get it more you
see it more if it's a well made movie a
great movie is a movie that repays that
kind of attention a lousy movie you
watch it once or twice and you're done
yes there's nothing more to it but
really good films I think bear that kind
of attention on so you just begin to see
what everybody has done to make that
film rich and full and that's what makes
a great movie
you